salut à tous on commence c'était très
fort avec un magnifique casse tête il en
existe que 24 exemplaires dans le monde
en tout cas qui sont faits comme ça qui
sont terminés c'est un casse tête de
chêne cas des puzzles vous souvenez on a
fait le mécanisme a avec eux on a fait
le architecture avec eux et là on fait
la version ultime de la scriptum cube et
du coup c'est la scriptum cube 2
pourquoi de luxe parce que c'est des
beaux matériaux elle été augmenté par
contre elle a une difficulté de 4 sur 5
et allah je crois seulement 18 m'ouvrant
pour l'ouvrir donc voilà on va voir si
on met quatre heures ou 4 heures et
demie avant d'attaquer cette dinguerie
rappelons nous quand même que nous avons
un contrat pour cette année qui va nous
permet de financer énormément de projets
qui est un contrat réalisé avec normes
epn le partenaire du jour bienvenue dans
les dossiers il nord des vérités presque
nickel oui les dossiers du nord vpn
sponsorisé par nord européenne
aujourd'hui nous allons découvrir la
véritable histoire de christophe colomb
qui a réussi à traverser l'atlantique à
grande vitesse grâce à sa voile noir epn
ce qui me paraît normal puisqu'il s'agit
du vpn le plus rapide du marché et le
plus simple d'utilisation grâce à sa
connexion automatique mais saviez-vous
que pour ses voyages vers les indes
christophe colomb avait eu une idée
remarquable il changer son ip pour se
connecter sur les sites de réservation
d'hôtels confort ça ils économisaient
pas mal de pesos pour lui son équipage
ce qui lui a permis d'acheter trois
bateaux quand même ces trois bateaux
d'ailleurs la niña lapinta et la santa
maría est également équipé de north bay
pn pour se connecter en toute sécurité
dans le wifi public des ports pas con
christophe colomb pareil pour celui des
tavernes et des auberges également dans
le carnet de route de christophe colomb
que nous avons retrouvés nous avons pu
découvrir que grâce à north bay peine il
pouvait continuer le soir dans sa cabine
directement sur le bateau et qu'il était
dans le monde à regarder ses programmes
préférés en streaming depuis ces
contrées lointaines ou au contraire
faire découvrir des programmes étrangers
lorsqu'il rentrait en espagne ou en
italie ne l'avait pas le times
christophe colomb si vous cherchez un
vpn alors faites comme cet explorateur
qui selon la légende avec cliquez sur le
lien dans ma description pour bénéficier
de l'offre actuelle il paraît même que
s'il n'était pas satisfait en 30 jours
ils étaient remboursés alors merci
normes epn et à bientôt pour une
nouvelle vérité presque nickel bon on
est parti on est parti on visite d'abord
un petit peu cette boîte alors cette
boîte a priori loïc à la combe fasse
exactement donc si face on à la phase la
phase du bas alors c'est un peu on peut
un peu appuyé dessus là ça doit s'ouvrir
j'imagine peut-être comme ça attire
évidemment
le ur mais on peut moins appuyé à ça ça
tourne complètement abbas est ouvert
c'est terminé non je rigole ça nous est
déjà arrivé sur quelques cas statu quo
n'a pas publié les trucs que j'ouvre en
une seconde 12 écrans gibbons balles à
aden ah oui ça ça bouge alors tout ça
qui bouge là
ok
comme vous pouvez le constater axes les
plus petites barrettes s'élève
à bâle descendent aussi apparemment a
tendance à se lève et sa descente de
côté peut-être tout à fait ça se lève et
ça c'est des cents sur chaque face
on a un point de départ on a pas mal de
lettres qui sont répétés ici là quand on
l'élève
j'imagine de la même manière et on
en a beaucoup moins de ce côté
pour ne pas dire
on en a pas du tout de ce côté
est ce qu'il ya des choses de marquer
peut-être à l'intérieur quand on ouvrait
qu'on libère parce qu'on a eu aucune
indication sur le point de départ donc
il faut vendre compares 2 0 et qu'on
fasse une bonne exploration en bonne et
due forme pour pas faire le fab ou qui a
préfère à la j'avais pas vu j'avais pas
très bien explorer c'est arrivé ça loïc
[Musique]
bon on imagine qu'il va y avoir un code
un code particulier donc j'ai juste de
toutes ces lettres là qui sont écrites
et qui sont abbaoui d'aliens et qui sont
complètement similaire aux lettres que
j'ai sur les barrettes mobile
là j'ai un espèce de b comme ça inversé
ou de juger que je retrouve par exemple
ici là ça nous fait le s là comme pour
la scriptum j'imagine qu'on le retrouve
quelques
pharmacies voilà on le retrouve ici là
le est ce que je vois moi de ce côté
c'est le sk ici eh ben on va checker qui
a bien tout l'air
[Musique]
donc on a bien ici l'aller les douze
lettres qu'on a c'est bien les douze
lettres qu'il ya autour mais pas dans le
même ordre dans le même sens des fois
c'est en face des fois c'est sur l'autre
côté le seul truc qui n'existe pas c'est
que j'ai pas derrière une languette j'ai
pas la lettre qui seraient sur la même
face du cube c'est le seul truc donc je
pense que comme il ya une deux trois
quatre cinq il ya cinq positions par
barrett donc il va falloir trouver le
code
ça laisse quand même pas mal de
possibilités 1 5 5 positions possibles
sur sur 12 face c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal du tout et on a des
espèces de petites indicateurs de
couleur en dessous quoique je peux si ça
vaut quelque chose puisque là tout est
blanc de ce côté tout est bon pour ton
info je me tiens dans la lumière
prochain oui tout est blanc là là donc
on a noir le trou on va dire acajou et
l'aac ajoute claire noir neutre
acajou acajou marron
l'autre j'ai essayé de mettre les 3
neutres donc c'est une excuse de à
inverser le a inversé il est
il est là et le inversée j'ai dit
c'était c'était neutre neutre neutre
faire correspondre comme quand il était
fermé
parce qu'en fait ça ça nous donne un peu
comme un comme un pantone la sas et le
blanc qu'on a là là c'est le noir qu'on
a fait ici ça c'est du vrai blanc parce
qu'il ya du vrai blanc un moment donné
des nuances de teintes la théorie est
pas mal maintenant à vérifier quand même
que je vois bien ce qui à quoi ouais ça
c'est un vrai blanc comme pour lui ça
donc on sait un noir comme lui le ca 70
neutre comme lui
ici on pourrait dire acajou fond c'est
un peu comme lui et l'acajou claire
exactement comme lui lui d'ailleurs il
serait en phase du bon si la théorie est
bonne là on voit bien que ces deux
couleurs là sont exactement la même que
cette couleur là
donc je le mets en face paris pour
l'assaut y à l'envers c'est celui que
j'ai là il est plutôt blank neutre je
crois donc je peux le mettre sur le
blanc voilà et l'espèce de ça on l'a dit
c'est plus sur le neutre que sur le
blanc ah voilà
voilà et bah c'était la théorie n'est
pas forcément
dans la pratique c'est vrai surtout que
j'ai en train de me dire ce que j'ai
enfoncé du coup je vois plus qu'il ya
derrière non mais je le relèverai le cas
échéant je veux le faire sur toutes les
faces peut-être ça va débloquer quelque
chose alors là je n avais qu une
apostrophe en l'air tiens ça me rappelle
qu'on faisait le jeu à deux avec des
énigmes à celle il a qu un verset qui
mangent une chèvre ah oui je dois tout à
fait le premier symbole fabien ont des
jambes avec des boucles de dire des gens
des bulls mais je ne vois pas de jambes
des gens avec des bunds ou alors un mec
qu'elle les yeux foncés avec une petite
barbe jamais décrit si mal à l'inversé
ah bah ça date un de ceux que j'ai
enfoncé alors attend lui gelé me
du coup en face du blanc abbas est lui
très bien donc lui c'est la cage ou
plutôt foncée donc lui il est en face du
blanc donc j'ai dit acajou plutôt foncée
ok ce irec la csu qui en face c'est
plutôt du noir je vais mais là et cette
espèce de cas c'est plutôt d'une blanche
trop
donc là il se passe rien là j'ai une
sorte de l alors c'était lui donc lui
c'est plutôt neutre
puis 70 m après lui c'est plutôt blanc
et lui c'est l'espèce de à l'inversé
mais c'est le petit truc c'est plutôt un
acajou clair ça voilà donc là il sera en
face c'est pas mal ok et j'essaie de ne
pas appuyer sur les trucs pour pas les
remonter le s6 l'acajou foncé
corps le 3 il a disparu et le jeu aussi
maintenant
c'est pauline je cherche
il était en face du blanc sait pas ce
que je cherche
oui lui je le cherche lui c'est donc
noir j'ai dit qu'il était en face d'une
neutre
donc lui c'est et noir
est donc là il me manque un lui les
aligner c'est à lui que je cherche et
lui il a un cran vers le bas ce doit
être lui donc lycée le neutre et lui il
était un cran vers le bas et donc lui
c'est le neutre
aprilia l'autre côté aussi d'ailleurs
des trucs 1 2 ans
et
est
payé
et et
et pourtant date est horrible mais se
trouve que j'ai peut-être foiré sur 1
alors je vous propose de voir ce que je
vais faire en accéléré vous essayez de
tout refaire un coup pour voir ce qui se
passe ce que j'ai peut-être pas été bien
les symboles en face les bonnes couleurs
c'est un peu dur il ya quand même des
nuances entre la haie lax et entre leïla
qui sont pas si claires donc j'avais
tout lever
enlevant tout bien il faudrait que je
termine par les mêmes comme ça je
pourrais m'en souvenir
[Musique]
à enfoncer ses
os
et ben ça c'est ouvert on va lui je peux
pas leur entrée c'est assez ouvert
d'accord donc en fait et oui mais après
si je me suis j'ai pu accès c'est à la
fois une bonne nouvelle parce que ça
avance mais par contre j'ai pu accéder
je peux plus les relever pour voir ce
qu'il ya derrière
mais j'ai peut-être des infos que j'ai
besoin ailleurs derrière ça on va voir
le y comme ça il est noir
et le petit a inversé il est blanc
et du coup c'est quand ça s'est lâché
dans ma main où j'ai pu pousser comme ça
ok c'est ça fonctionne
jusqu'ici tout va bien lui est belle oui
je sais pas du coup puisque je peux pas
le lever lui il est blanc et le u comme
ça il est comme ça eh ben j'ai juste à
essayer les combinaisons ont l'art en
voilà un groupe à
quand je quand je débloque regarde ça ça
eun locke le claque qu'on entend je vous
fais voir le claque qu'on entend c'est
ça qui se poussent varrault et donc je
peux m'appuyer j'imagine que voilà je
peut refermer
et du coup là j'ai dû bouger quelque
chose parce que j'arrive voilà est donc
en faisant ça donc gérer accès si je
veux aux anciens le s2 scriptum c'était
celui-là ça c'était bon le 3 je me
souviens plus le gg dit qu'il était noir
donc puisqu'il ya que celui du milieu
que je me souviens plus en vrai j'ai
juste passé les cinq types opposition
sadok neutre ouais ok donc là c'est pas
mal ça tout s'ouvre comme ça et après
c'est très très solide il n'y a plus
rien qui bouge tant que tant que ça
c'est enclenchant du
après si je tourne il ne se passe
il ya deux côtés
si je tourne ici à là je peux tourner
maintenant
ça peut quand même temps qu'en tournoi
16 minutes c'est plutôt rapide sachant
que 16 minutes avec du blabla 4 4 sur 5
c'était la difficulté sur le site
scriptum
scriptum cube luxe 2022 mars 2022 ou
alors c'est la troisième peut-être y en
a 24 indé comme ça alors qu est ce qu on
a 12 ans quand même à l'intérieur nous
avons un petit cadeau que je vais
déballer tout de suite après c'est
peut-être moi qui ai trouvé le bon truc
que c'est des fois tu sais parler casse
tête une fois tu mets une vie sur un
truc où ton pote i passi deux filles
fait balancer ça et des fois tu as des
trucs qui sont essentielle dure qu'il
ait fait très très vite
une petite frayeur égyptienne j'ai quoi
félicitations le minotaure a été vaincue
mais c'était le truc du minotaure
d'accord on dirait que les secrets du
labyrinthe ont été résolus mais en
êtes-vous certain
résolu philippe risoli
alors ils disent est ce que vous êtes
certain ça veut dire qu'il ya peut-être
autre chose à l'intérieur de la boîte tu
peux le constater vous pouvez le
constater par vous même je crois qu'il
ya un truc qui est caché qui s'est
défait qui devrait pas être comme ça
jusque là très clairement je ce doit
être un faux seins faux planchers clic
il s'est enlevé durant le transport et
qui fait que j'ai pas trop de mal à
trouver qui est un taux plancher parce
que c'est sous le faux plancher c'est
quoi ça c'est aussi du fil d'ariane mais
pour retrouver son chemin dans le
labyrinthe et parler comme ça ryan on a
des témoignages à laver un petit accent
d'ici là et du coup à tembisa peut-être
autre chose peut-être ça je peux le
sortir ou pas ça très agaçant c'est dire
qu'on peut le sortir mais qu'en fait on
peut pas si on peut on peut on peut le
sortir et du coup ça c'est le truc qui
tournait en bas d'accord à oui ok ça ça
doit être un système en vrai pour
renfermer le faux plancher dedans et ça
a dû garder un peu sur le transport
comme l'ont envoyé france
voilà ça sert au mit ensuite la lamal et
romy schneider ou et la malédiction je
vais la remettre évidemment ça je le
remets dedans ça je l'avais tourner s'il
avait tourné comme en
navette on est comme ça donc il faut que
je tente comme ça et après il faut
rembourser ça donc il faut appuyer sa et
après ouais ça ça libère sa serre on est
pareil pour les quatre côtés grecs
c'est un magnifique casse tête mais
rondement mené loïc très rondement menée
et écouter difficulté catcheur 5 je n'ai
pas ressenti comme ça hein
personnellement la seule difficulté
c'était de ne pas se tromper dans les
couleurs et de et de comprendre quand
même qu'il fallait pousser le truc mais
ça ça se fait tout seul en manipulant
comme tu veux pas que satan moi c'est
vraiment avec mon pouce ça a fait clic
alors évidemment ça doit être des
milliers d'heures de travail à imaginer
des centaines d'heures à concevoir
s'arrête un très bel objet bravo une
qualif de sel merci beaucoup de me
l'avoir envoyée je trouve très chouette
je voulais un lien vers une canne et
aussi dans la description ils ont sorti
un jeu mobile de réflexion ils sortent
un petit peu des choses physiques pour
aller vers des choses virtuelles si vous
avez envie de voir ça je vous le mets
également dans la description et merci
bien sûr alors bndes avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo là je le fais à la voir
parce que je trouve que sa ténacité ça
vous évite de penser au fait que j'ai
oublié d'enregistrer cette partie devant
la caméra merci à eux le lien vers la
belle offre et dans la description vous
savez pas quoi lire cet été sur la plage
peut-être c'est bon de reprendre le
pouvoir de la mémoire parce que j'ai
sorti un livre entier de suivre je vous
en ai parlé il ya pas longtemps au mois
de mai il est toujours disponible donc
il est au format digital au format
papier au format audio giannoli avec ma
propre voie
c'est pas si pour un utilisateur
j'aurais plus ferme et orange à tout le
long un gars super sur alors et que tu
es la mémoire fausse a fait le pouvoir
en tient un concept la voter pour ce
concept dans les commentaires et vous
mais le livre en lire dans la
description n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner prenez soin de vous passer un
excellent était à lundi prochain 18
heures à très bientôt donc ciao